the notion that someone that you married
for a few years has rights to a decade
or decades or even a lifetime of your
future income is absolutely absurd to me
given that men and women are equal under
the you know the guys you know feminism
today let's talk about that hypergamy I
basically sit here in my life and go
[__] like what do I do right I If a
woman dates lateral and up and a
mandates or sorry a woman dates lateral
and up in a mandate sort of lateral and
down when it comes to success and
finances status and a woman is
intelligent that hurts her earning
intelligence whatever like what the f
what do I do I'll tell guys in honesty
that you're in a better position to
marry a woman that's on the same part as
you if not higher right because that
almost removes most of the risk of
losing your nest egg in any future
income
um my ex-wife's a lawyer you know she's
very successful
um so that really wasn't a huge issue as
far as you know nest egg and division of
assets it was more dealing with you know
the child custody issues was that
daughter
um but for women that you know like you
like I assume that you've done well in
life you know you've raced cars
um I don't know you know what the total
record is although I am a huge card
Enthusiast but I don't watch racing I
don't it's weird because I love driving
supercars but I don't like watching
other people drive supercars I don't
find it as interesting to drive them
myself yeah I'm not gonna lie I don't
watch that much racing but now that I do
more commentating and I'm a host for I
do a little bit for F1 NASCAR and
IndyCar I obviously keep up with
everything but yeah yeah I really find
the job they did on the Netflix series
um drive to survive really good on the
formula one thing but setting that aside
um it's it's it's got to be difficult
for you if you're a successful woman to
find a guy and get into a long-term
relationship because the thing with
successful older guys is like Med Peak a
little bit later on in life than women
do right like men reach their sexual
Market peak in their late 30s and the
thing that women don't like is they peak
in their early 20s and that's just an
unfortunate reality of the Sexes and
it's always been that way men have
always been success objects to women and
women have always been Beauty objects to
men so men tend to date younger women go
into Peak though what does peak mean
well
um men are valued based on on their
competency skills what they can do
um you know that like like that little
Dent that they can put in the universe
sort of thing whereas men don't usually
care about women's degrees they don't
usually show a lot of interest in their
degrees on the wall framed in Mahogany
with little letters after the name sort
of thing it's Grand and it's Noble and
all that sort of stuff but there's no
guy that ever said oh yeah look at the
degree on her right guys will look at a
woman and say look at whatever on her
she's walking away sort of thing that's
how men operate you know their their
visual in the sense that they see women
as Beauty objects and they've always
been treated as Beauty objects even
though Society tries to change that
today so Peak then for women's
appearance is earlier value actually
um yeah it's actually based on a lot I
understand what the peak is because
fertility is Peaks money is Peak beauty
is what's what's the peak well that's
that's a definition that they're trying
to change today right because we women
have valued men based on what they can
bring to the table right like what
resources they have available to them to
provide and preside over the family and
the children and protect and all that
sort of stuff uh women's value has
historically always been around their
beauty and their fertility
um you know when they survey
cross-culturally across all continents
all religions and they show a lineup of
every man from 18 to like 75 I think the
survey was done under uh you know lineup
of women from all ages all the way up to
75 from 20. the universally almost all
pick about 22 23 year old women you know
as far as like beauty standards so
that's just the way that societies
always operated so as a beautiful
attractive women maybe you know such as
yourself that's also had a successful
career that's competent influential on
social media uh does commentating you
know let's say on race basic events and
stuff like that there's not a lot of
guys that are like oh my God she's
um you know her voice or or her
commentary on that program is so
valuable to me what guys look at is the
beauty aspect of a woman right like
that's that's why women wear makeup dye
their hair you know wear push-up bras
and accentuate you know their body
curves and their lines with things like
heels and stuff like that
um as much as Society wants to change
that today and say things like You're
Beautiful at any weight like that's one
of the big lies that I think that
feminism tells women is you're beautiful
at any size it's just not true right
there are standards that men are drawn
to when it comes to beauty and obesity
is not one of them not healthy either
like it's not healthy like I wouldn't
want to invite a woman that's obese and
diabetic into my life I don't want to
deal with that there's a evil
psychologist his name's Dr Ware Dr
Warren Farrell uh he's written several
books I think one one of the ones that
stood out was uh the myth of male power
and he's done a few others like the boy
crisis and things like that one of the
observations that he made over his
career like you know Decades of of
studying all this material is basically
that you can distill it down to that men
are success objects and women are Beauty
objects and that's how the Sexes view
each other do you think that's right
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong
that's just how we've always viewed each
other throughout history I don't know I
mean
I think we we don't grow and evolve
without a discussion without changes
so it would imply that there's nothing
wrong with anything and that there's no
need to grow and evolve and
you know I think that I don't know I
think that there's still a discussion
around that is that the right thing is
that is that right because they think
that you know when we expand on that and
we go into like value I think I saw
something that you had written that said
like if you took sex out of the uh
relationship 90 of women would have
nothing to offer yeah and if you took
money out of the relationship the 90 of
men would have nothing to offer women
explain that that's actually something
that I came across in comedy believe it
or not I get a lot of my material from
Comedy that I you know summarize in my
videos in my social media so if men lost
their their status their success the
wealth or influence their competency uh
in society then 90 of women probably
wouldn't stay with those guys like the
reason why women generally leave
relationships and marriages and women
leave marriages 80 of the time it's not
generally men that leave marriages it's
generally women that leave and when
women leave it's because they feel like
they can do better with another guy
right um this guy that I'm married to
that I've had my 2.1 kids in the white
picket fence in the station wagon he
just sits around and watches Sports all
day he's put on 150 pounds he can't keep
a job down he doesn't even know how to
change the light bulb I have to call my
dad to come over and take care of stuff
like that these are the sorts of things
that women don't want to deal with right
so when I speak to Men I'm constantly
telling them chase Excellence right like
you can't let your guard down you can't
retire you cannot stop you know pursuing
passion you cannot stop putting a dent
in Universe because if your wife your
woman your girlfriend wakes up in the
morning and she looks at you and thinks
to herself I'm stuck with a loser
there's a good chance she's probably
going to leave because marriage isn't
forever anymore you know the nod is
untied all the time
um we're not particularly good as a
species at monogamy so that's where that
notion comes from and on the flip side
of the coin I mean if a woman is like 90
of guys would leave relationships if sex
was removed from the equation if his
wife or his girlfriend all of a sudden
announced and said look I'm just going
to become celibate I've gotten right
with God I don't have sex anymore I'm
going to become you know the Virgin Mary
whatever he's going to be like huh
that's interesting because the reason
why I'm here is for access to easy
frequent and you know amazing sex that's
why you guys get married that's it
that's the main reason why guys are
getting married believe it or not they
think that when they get see the biggest
complaint that guys have when they get
married if you take a look at their
Google search history as they start
looking up words like why doesn't my
wife want to bang me why doesn't my wife
want to have sex with me how do I get my
wife to have sex with me could you
imagine being married as a man and
you're Google searching how do I get my
wife to have sex with me there's a lot
of marriages out there that are
completely sexless right so when you
remove sex from the equation and the sad
part of it is a lot of guys they won't
change that they'll just resort to
something like pornography so they won't
leave the relationship they won't end
the marriage it's generally not to their
advantage to do that because they'll
lose so much so they'll just stay
lose what
could be wealth could be future wealth
could be access to their kids it depends
it could be all those things so you're
saying there's nothing else that a woman
offers if it isn't sex they don't offer
Comfort they don't offer safety they
don't offer a companionship they don't
offer taking care of things they don't
offer planning nice things for someone
they don't offer cooking or cleaning or
I didn't say that like anything like
that no I didn't say that but women
don't offer safety to me I offer safety
to women yeah but all the other stuff
you're talking about Comfort
companionship love all that sort of
stuff of course but the main reason why
men get into relationships with women is
for sex what areas of value is it that
you believe a woman has Beyond has to be
more than sex well I I have greater
standards than just sex right like I
have girlfriends exactly you know she's
got great culinary skills she's fun to
be around we laugh we joke we have
similar interests like I like cycling so
we go for bike rides a lot in the
summertime so it's it's beyond just sex
but the main reason why men mate select
a woman is because of sexual intimacy
that's just the way like that's why
we're here on the earth to scatter seed
right we're not here to build
skyscrapers and Roads and drive electric
cars we're here to scatter seeds like
that's our buy that's our biological
imperative what do you think about the
idea that the world is overpopulated do
you believe in that or do you believe
it's not getting populated enough I
don't know I mean a lot of the stuff you
hear in mainstream media there's just so
much of it that I really question now
especially since the scandemic and that
you know that that game they put they uh
pulled up on us a few years ago it seems
pretty obvious to me when I'm on a
flight and I look out the window the
amount of barren Land There is out there
that we don't occupy so I don't really
buy this you know this notion that we're
overpopulating the Earth you know at the
stage of the game
um you know when I'm on a flight and
look at the window and there's humans
everywhere like ants then I'll say okay
maybe we have a problem but it seems
like it's not really an issue I don't
know what do you think no I don't think
so either I think that you know I mean
women are not having are getting married
later they're having kids later they're
not having as many I don't think couples
are are having as many kids as they used
to they're not needed for farming and
taking care of the property and various
different things that I think that in
many many decades ago was probably more
important I think that fertility is
probably down in general across the
board but especially in men testosterone
is definitely down a large degree you
probably know more about that statistic
than I do
um so I don't think that it's driving
driving the numbers up I think you want
to I mean if you want to go down the
rabbit hole on things like testosterone
I can I can blow your mind on that one
too I'd love it blow my mind if you like
this clip and you want to hear the whole
episode click at the bottom of your
screen